[Music]
[Music]
persona 5 second story dungeon the one
where you're stealing madura maze heart
has to mildly challenging puzzles both
located after the quests halfway point
if you're stuck at either of these spots
we have you covered if you found these
helpful why not hit the subscribe button
for more if you have any ideas requests
and tips yourself send them our way to
the discussion below puzzle number one
traveling through paintings the section
following the treasure hall safe room
features a series of large paintings and
some scaffolds as you should have
experienced earlier in the dungeon
entering these paintings is key to
making forward progress to get across
the scaffolds first run across the
desert painting then go through the red
arch in the painting with a mountain
then climb up the rock formation in the
green painting finally run along the
foreground of the orange painting and
jump out if you wish to explore the
entire area jump out of the green
painting and press the button nearby
this will reveal the boat painting you
can reach it by running across the
mountain painting when Morgan opposes a
question to you choose the first answer
this will knock your team on to the
floor here you can gain a bit of
experience by fighting a couple guards
[Music]
victory puzzle number two they say Yuri
knock-offs
when you reach the MC escher inspired
section of the dungeon you'll be tested
multiple times in identifying the real
site you're repainting pick the wrong
one and you'll have to fight some
enemies guessing is great if you want to
grind levels but not if you want to make
forward progress all you need to know
about the real site repainting is that
the woman is dressed in red a part of
her hair is draped over her shoulder and
there's a tree branch in the background
any paintings that are missing any of
these are the fakes if you enjoyed these
persona 5 tips give us a thumbs up and
subscribe to our channel for future
persona guides while you're there check
out our history of persona video thanks
for watching
[Music]